but there was like the the typical
tropes that a lot of people talk about
when dating somebody who is like
american or white
for example the shoe thing uh-huh the
shoe thing was a weird thing what was
that
like she just she didn't understand it
shooting like
us taking off her shoulders shoes yeah
like she didn't understand it
oh and and the funny thing was it's not
a problem i wasn't upset or anything
but from a person who grew up his whole
life taking off his shoes going into a
house
having your shoes in the house is
[ __ ] disgusting yeah
it's [ __ ] in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
have ed park vp here again today
cheers cheers um did you hear about
[ __ ] uh tiger woods
yeah he got into like a major [ __ ]
car accident
like right down south of here right pals
there it is or something yeah or
something i don't know what happened i
heard he got into the car crash with a
hyundai for like a young day
it was like some kind of hyundai event
oh my goodness yeah so he was driving a
brand new hyundai suv
or some [ __ ] and he got [ __ ] up pretty
bad dawg
like the genesis suv yeah i think it was
the genesis
bad publicity yeah i'm sorry i mean we
we care for tiger too
you're helping korean fries right
oh my gosh so what part of the car yeah
i know it's a very bad accordion look
but yeah i guess his leg got shattered
into pieces
he was trying to go to the masters this
year again um
i last saw him like he was doing some
charity with his son who's also prodigy
jesus like i think his son's gonna have
to continue his father's lives you know
what the hard part about that is man
like these people who are
just born winners yeah they don't know
how to do anything else besides win
yeah and you just strip that away from
him from a from a car accident
not because of old age not because
father time took it away from him
because of a [ __ ] car accident and
even like uh
in sports like when you get released
right yeah you see all these jocks
having no idea what to do after they
they
have to be forced to retire or something
right yeah
i saw uh so i'm a big seattle mariners
fan
like i grew up watching baseball up
there and we had the second baseman
just roided out the guy named bret boone
right
um my friend when i was going out to uh
art institute
he was a bouncer on the like just that
night
at some bar and he said brett boone had
came in
and it was just drunk as hell and he's
like [ __ ] this place and [ __ ] whatever
i'm bread boom and then he
they kicked him out the bar and he
dropped his pants and just
peed with his butt crate hanging out in
the middle of the
and then like his escorts put him in a
car and then he drove away next day he
was released
from the team oh my god and then on the
news he's like
bawling his eyes out crying and stuff
like makes me wonder what the [ __ ] was
somebody like that going through
yeah he like his whole personality is
just being a
jock and super cocky and he was doing
bad flips
like 20 years ago before bat flips were
cool you know
really yeah and like usually you're not
supposed to do that they're going to
bean you but then he's
super voided out yeah and then he just i
think because of like
jose canseco's book his numbers just
burr because he had to stop taking
steroids right
get released and that that whole you can
imagine that
athletic psyche a guy who used to hit 40
home runs a year
can't hit it out of the infield well
today's topic is going to be interesting
so
one of the things that uh people have
been asking about is like
i feel like a lot of people like dating
experience stuff right
yeah yeah and um i think for me growing
up
i i only pictured myself with like an
asian girl right
like i grew up in a very korean
household maybe not so much a korean
girl but some
some girl that was asian well after i
got
dumped the first time i'm like you know
what just
try dating people i just tried dating
anybody and everybody
and so one of the biggest misconceptions
is that people have thought that i've
never dated a white person before
and i have i've actually dated one white
girl before yeah just one
right and it was such a interesting
experience right
i have relatives like my my uh cousin
jason
he's married to a white girl right she's
dope she's she's [ __ ] dope like she's
super cool i love her to death you know
so in my mind
it's not like i haven't seen it in my
family yeah you know what i mean i think
i have like a second cousin
with like a white wife and my dad's
cousin um is also half white half korean
yeah so
yeah i think it's not irregular enough
especially if you're around tacoma
yeah yeah it was it's just one of those
weird things where like
i'm not sure if this was for you but i
feel like asian dudes always have this
odd perception of like an asian guy
dating a white girl makes them feel like
you won
or something ah yeah you know what i
mean like that's the
cries that's true like you nab the white
girl it's like what does that mean
i don't understand why that's so special
like what's so special about that i'm
not shooting on white girls i'm just
saying like
i think we were told growing up like
because of everything we saw in media
magazines was
the cindy crawford blonde bombshell
yeah but those girls that's not even
like a racing they're just fine as [ __ ]
it'd be fun as [ __ ] be anything it
doesn't matter you know
but yeah i but i've generally
experienced
the side where in high school
um i was sitting in this keyboard class
and i'm sitting between one of the girls
that's considered one of the hottest
seniors you know in the class and this
guy that they call
stork because he looks like a [ __ ]
stork what the hell his nose is like you
know
so they call him stork and then i don't
know
i forgot why the conversation got into
this but she basically said
he's way better looking than you you
know this guy named stork
then me his name is stork yeah and she's
like yeah office
i would she told me to my face he's way
hotter than you i would never date
someone like you and i was just like
why am i ugly yeah that i had a
i had one of those things in those times
like where i
did like actually first realized like
they see us differently
maybe yeah like i had never thought i
was ugly then yeah yeah yeah
yeah so that that's where i'm coming
from
where i saw a lot of guys like because
my young's like gen x especially
i think for them i heard that a lot like
oh god with white girl get with white
girl
kind of stuff where it's like man um
i think there's a this fringe group
i don't know if you've heard of asian
identity
like the [ __ ] is that corny ass [ __ ]
it's not good
okay i'm not a fan of it celebration
yeah it's just it's just little dick
energy let's just say yeah
it bothers the [ __ ] out of me kind of
thing where it's not helping us
you know yeah it's more or less it's
more putting us in a box than anything
and there's
a lot of complaining about it yeah
there's a lot of that yeah
but i generally growing up because of
that experience was like
[ __ ] you then i'm never gonna date a
white girl yeah right
and so i generally spent most of my life
dating other asian women
until i had to go back home and
they just had to take whatever you could
say anything
that's what so i i lose 100 pounds
and someone actually gave me [ __ ] it was
just like why are you losing all this
weight like who for like all these
methods
and crazy people out there yeah and so
yeah like and the idea of settling down
you know
in the middle of nowhere kind of had to
become a reality
and if i'm gonna stay here for a long
time like i gotta pee with somebody
right
yeah yeah so i look towards settling but
what about you where did you
well for me it was when i when i was in
college i
i started dating whoever and whatever
right like the idea of being rejected i
became really comfortable with that
okay so you know you would try to mack
on some girls hit on them you know
obviously the sloppy little fat asian
dude but i was a funny dude yeah like
you know
spark up a conversation at a bar or
whatever and i got rejected a lot but
anybody who did say yes
it was like i got you [ __ ]
yeah it's my lucky day no but we um
there was a girl who was in
i went to a community college called
cosumnes river college out in sacramento
yeah
and in these classes they're relatively
small it's a community college
so you know sparking up a conversation
with somebody was relatively easy and
there was this girl
and i would even say she was like
completely she's not she's white
american
yeah but she was polish right so she had
like
she obviously didn't speak the native
language from where she's from
but she's like first generation her
parents came here or whatever what not
or she's like second gen or first gen
yeah
yeah whatever so you know that was my
first experience right
but it was so weird because i think
because she grew up so
white american and asian american
experiences are so different
i i had a lot of trouble uh connecting
with her
on a lot of things just because she grew
up in like a loving household
okay she grew up with like positive
reinforcement
and all this weird [ __ ] you can be
anything you want yeah what kind of
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] is that
but there was like the the typical
tropes that a lot of people talk about
when dating somebody who is like
american or white
for example the shoe thing the shoe
thing was a weird thing what was that
like she just she didn't understand it
shooting like us taking off her
shoulders
shoes yeah like she didn't understand it
oh and
and the funny thing was it's not a
problem i wasn't upset or anything
but from a person who grew up his whole
life taking off if she shoes going into
a house
having your shoes in the house is
[ __ ] disgusting yeah
it's [ __ ] disgusting not even on a
cultural level
right yeah common sense level you could
be walking any
on anything anywhere right you're gonna
walk around downtown l.a and put those
filthy [ __ ] shoes
on my floor are you [ __ ]
how am i gonna do yoga are you [ __ ]
nuts
yeah sometimes you feel like like they
have this entitlement to keep their
shoes on for some reason yeah why do you
what are you talking about because your
feet smell [ __ ] wash your feet then the
[ __ ] are you doing stop with this men by
[ __ ] dude
stop wearing your boots with just no
socks but yeah i remember i was
explaining to her
kind of like yeah i think it's kind of
weird like wearing shoes in the house
she's like well why i'm like
like you could have stepped in [ __ ] and
you're just trying all these well you
could always just like
you know wash the floor and i'm like or
you could never be in that situation
ever exactly and i remember too just
having this conversation
and i wouldn't say it was irritating it
was just kind of odd that i had to
explain to her before she came into my
place why she has to take off her shoes
like number one [ __ ] is my [ __ ]
house
yeah that's why you don't need to know
anything else the only thing you need to
know is that in this house
my rules take off your [ __ ] shoes now
make sweet love to me
i think that was the like so
at a young age in college i was
at um this bar and
yeah it's an asian bar so there's
generally asian people and i would just
talk to asian women
and one day there's this white girl
there
and she's drunk but she's like talking
she's like
you know i only date asian guys what are
you i'm like i'm korean
oh my last boyfriend was korean right
and then i'm like
oh my god yeah this is my lucky day
right but then i i
i heard it on the flip side like um
for us we're like this is so [ __ ]
awesome
but then apparently when asian girls
like if
the white dude was like oh i only date
asian girls
creepy it's creepy right but for me i
was like
so um so when i had matched
uh with this girl online
and i drove [ __ ] two hours out to
just see her because that's how far away
i was
and yeah she was white and she wanted to
go to
chat the teppanyaki
and um she's like i love korean food
yeah
that's that's kind of what the flavor
was where it was like she was more
interested in asian [ __ ] yeah
about the conversation we were getting
into and getting more into the food she
wanted to learn korean
and then she was like she goes oh my god
have you heard of just kidding films
like bart and jio's because i i love
them like they're like my
favorite like favorite like asian uh
whatever geo's mexican niche
she was just like i i didn't even
mention that i
i knew that yeah during the day but then
i told her later that you actually know
them or whatever
and then it started like her fan-ness
came out
fandom but then also i started seeing
like how she
only like she didn't like the music i
listened to and the only music she
wanted to listen to around me was kpop
she only wanted to watch [ __ ] that you
don't listen to yeah
she only wanted to watch kdramas she
only want to watch korean movies and
only wanted korean food and i was kind
of
feel understanding this fetishization
let's say
out of it yeah isn't that weird though
now like where
i say it's it's depending on the
perspective of certain kids right
because like when we grew up
there wasn't much of any asian thing
that was considered cool
yeah at all yeah you know nothing was
cool nothing
nothing was cool at all like chops like
the fact chopsticks were weird
eating seaweed is weird eating now you
see that [ __ ] at costco
and then now i have a white person
coming up to me like bro
have you tried seaweed before it's like
hey sheepseky i know exactly what that
is dude
[ __ ] kid food [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of my face you know but now it's like in
this era where
it's weird how small korea is and the
the amount of
influence this small little country has
over the whole [ __ ] world
this k-wave thing they exported culture
yeah amazing like the only other country
that did that was america
the movies it's [ __ ] nuts and i'll
say something about kpop that might not
be so great and then i have a white
person how dare you speak about korean
people that way
i'm like first of all you're not even
talking about korean people you're
talking about a very specific genre
yeah of like a very small genre of what
korean people are it's like this music
that we've exported out to you that you
guys
eat like it's [ __ ] candy yeah you
know and so
um in my when i was starting to see that
before we continue with this podcast
let's talk about one of our great
sponsors
better help is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
my friends
well guess what that's a lot of us but
with better help
you can get the counseling and the help
that you need from the comfort
of your home better help will assess
your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating in
under
48 hours and no it is not a crisis line
it is not self-help it is professional
counseling done securely
on line in fact so many people have been
using betterhelp that they are
recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
so don't wait my friends and make sure
that you help yourself to some better
help
you'd be surprised how much counseling
and therapy will help you out
it's helped me a ton and i am happier
today than i was two or three years ago
even though i told myself i was happy so
remember my friends this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp
and brain listeners can get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
genius once again that's betterhelp.com
genius b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com genius yeah
she just kind of i just kind of felt
like a dildo let's just say that
she's like hey are you gonna like dye
your hair blonde or something like that
like am i gonna take care of my skin you
just wake up you have glitter on your
[ __ ]
glitter on your face and she's like what
the [ __ ] is this i just want you to look
different that's all
does she have a problem like this white
girl with the food you're eating or any
of that
oh she didn't want to eat any of the
food yeah i mean i don't think she was
very open
okay but this is what i'm talking about
well culturally things become a little
weird
right where it's not like
she wasn't a bad person or anything else
like that she just wasn't really open to
food she wasn't really open to anything
else like
it's almost like she wanted to separate
me as a person
and my culture it's like that doesn't we
all come in a package
it's everything my parents come in to
package everything else right it's not
like i was hyper serious about dating
this girl but who knows right
she was really cool she was super
[ __ ] funny and i enjoyed being around
her
but that was the weird part where it was
almost like when we had these
conversations
it felt like she just wanted to date
david
minus the korean part it's because she
never thinks of herself as
her the white girl yeah yeah yeah
white americans don't ever have to think
about being white yeah at all ever
like this is the norm this is how
everybody why do you keep thinking about
being asian it's like because everyone
around me reminds me
that i'm a [ __ ] that's the problem i
had with
my my ex was when i would
share these [ __ ] up stories that was
happening me at the store
like at first it was very consoling like
i'm sorry i can't believe that happened
then it turned to eye rolling and okay
it
like i know you don't like it there like
okay
like and i
was just kind of getting to feel like
she didn't want to hear about any of
this [ __ ]
yeah but this is happening to me because
i'm asian yeah
and you love everything about me because
i'm asian but you won't like
like stand up for me yeah the situation
well it's because everybody likes to
pick and choose what they like about a
culture right yeah
so that's like typically what a lot of
uh black americans feel
it's like you get to imitate our culture
you get to love our music our style the
way that we say things everything else
but when we're in trouble and some real
[ __ ] happens you go well that's because
you're lazy it's like
hold on a second like you specifically
want to only take apart the stuff that
you enjoy
but you know it makes people feel used
and very dirty
yeah you know like you it sucks did you
ever have a problem where she just
didn't
relate to you like culturally or like
race wise because of that
i think like the only thing that that
was very odd was like our
there's something about somebody who
didn't grow up around
a culture outside of yours where you
don't feel connected with them
right you feel like this odd distance
you know whether it's about
social subjects or just things that you
like aside from us like hooking up and
like
joking around and having fun you know
drinking with each other
other than that there wasn't any
substance behind it right yeah and it
goes down to breaking
it it breaks down to even like uh how
you solve situations or how you
how you're around people and friends
yeah right those small little things
like for example one of the things that
i noticed and
um that was different about her compared
to the other asian girls that i would
date she was very vocal about stuff that
um
she didn't like or didn't want to do
despite the fact that a group
of people were down to do something
right there wasn't this
idea of a collectivism and i think that
that's what asian people have a lot
right
so for example let's say me you uh paul
khalif or whatever there's like five or
six of us out there right and you guys
are oh let's go let's go drink at uh
cafe blue and you guys are all hyped
and i go now i'm not gonna go
right let's go somewhere else i most
likely i wouldn't do that i'd be like
if everybody's down [ __ ] it let's just
go there and see if we can go somewhere
else
right and that's usually what would
happen but with her
specifically it was like she always had
to be vocal about what she said and her
opinions always felt like facts
yeah and i didn't like that i'm not
saying i'm not sure if this is a white
person thing i think it's a very
american thing
yeah you know where it's like your
opinions are facts
not just it's not it's not just your
specific thought it's like this is what
i say
objective truth exactly and that [ __ ]
used to irritate the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
me
and at that point too is like you
there's something off about us like
culturally things aren't really meshing
well
and the opinions being fax thing is the
thing that irritated me the most
i i felt close to that i mean that's
pretty much why we
broke up like it was a
big [ __ ] show so um
i was i like i said i explained to her
about
the situation i get into and the races
racism i face
right and and more and more she's
getting disconnected with that [ __ ]
and one day she actually visits me at
the store you know she takes the road
trip
like bless her you know and um
she's sitting behind the counter with me
and guess what
all these customers that can be really
shitty are
so nice so nice to this girl
on the counter you know and they're
really like hey you did good
you did girl good cause i'm with this
girl and whatever
but this guy comes up to me and
i'm listening to hip hop right just on
my bluetooth speakers
and then uh this guy comes up and he's
like
what's up you like brown music you know
what the [ __ ]
what like it's like why you like
listening to hip-hop
i'm like yeah why not right yes man you
soft
you're a [ __ ] i'm like this is i don't
know her seriously
and my my girl is just sitting right
there she's watching this whole thing
going down i'm like
why why dude yeah he's like i'm like
what did i do to you
yeah and he goes [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you
he just starts [ __ ] with me out of the
blue and i
take his kombucha and i'm like you know
what dude just get out yeah leave
he just [ __ ] you i'll [ __ ] you up don't
i would have looked at him i was like
i'm stopped you're buying kombucha [ __ ]
exactly how [ __ ] dare you call me
soft and you're over here drinking
fermented probiotics you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was irony of it honestly i was like
this is [ __ ] ridiculous are you from
l.a
yeah he is so he's trying to fight me
in front of my girl and all is going to
until i just tell him get the [ __ ] out
and just leave
and i finally look at her and i'm like
see you see this this is my life
yeah and she goes all i saw
was two idiots fighting you know
what the [ __ ] and i was like you don't
get it
you don't get it and she started crying
she started crying she was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
what is it cause i'm white and i'm like
yes
yeah it was [ __ ] you why don't you go
back to korea
and i'm like here's me calling out your
white privilege
yeah and here's you telling me to go
back to a country i wasn't born in
it's it's so funny too because when you
when you look at that she goes i just
see two idiots fighting i was like he
literally said would you like that brown
music
saying the most racist [ __ ] ever he
basically said you like black people
music
yeah you know it was he was saying it
straight up like black people music
brown music you like that stuff
and that [ __ ] is [ __ ] because black
people make like it's it's already there
you know but like you don't see that as
anything racial even though he
literally brought color in there yeah
that's so odd and it was
arguments like maybe you should have
been listening to something else i was
like like
yeah i don't know third eye blind right
yeah like what the [ __ ] did you want
like why do i have to change myself to
make you feel comfortable yeah
that's the odd thing too like even that
statement's very weird you know
like why didn't you change what you were
listening to make him feel comfortable
why do i have to yeah why it was all
these things she kept telling me this
advice to submit
constantly and i'm like i don't think
you understand a korean man
yeah i'm not gonna do that [ __ ] for
anybody
but it's even for her in her case right
it's if
if we talk about another type of
situation right it's like
when we when we talk about women who are
you know
sexually assaulted right because of the
way that they dress and if i told her
it's like
she had a world longer skirt yeah victim
thing you know why
victim blame you [ __ ] that's not how it
works it's it's not how it works at all
there's no empathy in that [ __ ] you're
not looking at
she's not even looking at you as a
person at that point and she
that was the weird part is like i think
you just like all this [ __ ] about
my culture but you're trying to tell me
to deal with my problems the way you do
and just erase the culture right yeah
erase the color out of me
yeah you erase that culture attitude you
know
and here's the thing like
she is from the appalachian trail
like which is you know that east coast
mountain range and so that's like
kentucky
north carolina kind of area [ __ ] and
her going out to the middle of nowhere
where i am
is a dream come true for her holy [ __ ]
that's so cool she loved it
and dude she wanted a horse
she she loved horses she was just like
looking at
the this yard we had this big property
we have at our store it's just like
she wants to have a horse she wants to
ride horses she was cool like
things i don't know what in the [ __ ] she
look i got a drink
you know where that trailer is parked i
could picture my horse right there
just galloping away every day and she
kept talking about
like this future we would have together
and yeah getting married and spending my
the rest of my life out there running
the store with her and my little half
white kids
and i thought about that and just
thought about how much i would resent
that life
100 yeah that'd be really [ __ ] weird
like you want me to come home every
night
exhausted from people assaulting me and
you're going to tell me to just
pull my bootstraps up yeah
[Laughter]
all i saw were two [ __ ] idiots
like and yeah that's pretty much where
we had to end it because i was like you
keep
talking about getting married and you
want to move out here and i would resent
that
yeah and she said what do you want to do
move back to l.a
i said yeah yeah with a bunch of those
queers
it's like yup i love you questions yeah
i love it that's what i want to do and
she was finally broke up
and and now i'm here in l.a so that's
[ __ ] crazy man
like i i wouldn't even know how to deal
with it i don't understand like how sad
you were to even date somebody like
i was desperate serious face
i was desperate yeah i didn't see
a lot of people man yeah and like
i don't know as much as i would put
myself
out there um the only asians i was
around was church people
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i really
realized
that's not the type of relationship i
don't think i want to be in either yeah
and let me try to look for this normal
all-american relationship
i got what i got that's so weird too
that she would say that even though she
loves like
quote-unquote korean culture and stuff
right but she can't see it that way
she wanted to like move in with
me and my mom like i wasn't living with
my mom at the time you know
and she wanted to move with my mom so
she could learn korean and learn to cook
korean food
and she wanted to work at the store and
raise children be a stay-at-home mom
damn just looking at my life running a
gas station
come on didn't that scare you that would
have scared the [ __ ] out yeah it scared
me
like when you had these moments and
you're like this is all this is what my
life is
yeah that scares the [ __ ] and nobody's
going so far nobody has actually helped
me
from any of these yeah you know
and um being in this relationship
although
like i feel loved and such
um it definitely didn't have a bright
future
where if i i'm already calling out that
i'm going to resent this
that's the scary part when i when i was
working at my parents store 2
and i remember my dad told me like
so back in the day my dad would i would
always work at the store right yeah and
then my brother would never work there
and so later on like he told me it's
because my brother did really well in
school so he has a really bright future
ahead of
you him and i'm like yeah what about me
yeah he goes you were never good at
school
so i made you come to the store because
you have to make a living somehow
i'm like hold on a second that's how
little you believed in me
the bar was so low you're like how can
you fail at anything else
exactly so he was thinking like you're
going to take over this weave store
like that's as far as he thought my
abilities were you know
and i was like [ __ ] like if that was my
life
just being in the store you know like i
said i'm very grateful that's that's
that store
you know fed us you know put a roof over
our head and everything else like that
but to think that that would have been
my end goal would would have killed me
on the inside
yeah not not the part that i'm a
business owner but because i didn't
have any of my own dreams where i could
have made something achievable so
even as an artist yeah i think yeah i
think it would have killed me on the
other side where would you
have time to create you know i would
have just changed the whole story i
probably would have called it like
i know i believe or something you know
and i would have just you know done some
really fun and crazy stuff with it
yeah but other than that like i think i
would have definitely lived the life
where i would have regretted it like i
wish i would have done something else i
wish i could have done better
this podcast is brought to you by ship
station my friends if you are shipping
anything out if you deal with
any type of e-commerce from home you
have to get ship station it is
literally my favorite way of shipping
anything out because
they consolidate everything and make it
easy for me the
seller no matter how much you sell
shipstation makes it
super easy to manage and ship all your
orders from
all your sales channels faster cheaper
and more
efficiently you can import orders from
any sales channel
ship with any carrier access discounted
shipping rates
automate just about any shipping test
you'll spend a lot less time
on shipping and a lot more time growing
your business it doesn't matter what
you're selling it could be on amazon
etsy your own website ship station
funnels all your orders into one simple
interface
that can help you manage from anywhere
even your
cell phone if you are doing e-commerce
you do understand
how amazing shipstation is and if you
haven't used it before
it's going to change your life
specifically change your life by saving
you
freaking time use ship station
ship more in less time just use my offer
code geniusbrain to get a
60 day free trial that's two months free
of no hassle stress free shipping
just go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in geniusbrain that's
shipstation.com
enter offer code geniusbrain and make
ship happen
but thinking about that part scares me
the most like
that married with kids and like that's
it
like that's you're settled down there
and that's that was an original goal of
mine when i was 20 something years old
all i thought about was my very first
girlfriend marrying her
right having a house like in sacramento
and then having a kids and family and
this is i'm super
young at this point yeah and that's all
i thought about and i remember just
uh after you know i got dumped and
whatever what not and i'm like this is
stupid
like why why the [ __ ] okay first of all
did you want to be a stand-up comic yeah
like who the [ __ ] has a stand-up comic
with a [ __ ]
family in sacramento what the [ __ ] are
you talking about you loser
nothing made nothing made sense and then
after that like the idea of settling
settling down became very scary for me
yeah like i didn't want to settle down
with anybody
just because i felt like if i settled
down and i had kids i felt it was the
end of my life
i felt i felt the same yeah i felt the
same
but because but how old were you when
this was you said 20.
around 20 is when i kind of realized all
this [ __ ] yeah i was 33.
and it was like it's about time right
everyone's like pushing you
it's like finally finally and finally
yeah yeah yeah
saying that like they're assuming i'm
gonna get married now but it was
it was very daunting like i actually
gave me panic attacks
yeah and like i don't want to do this i
get scared nah man sometimes i wake up
next to mario's face i'm like oh my god
look at this face every day for the rest
of my life it wasn't about
spending the rest of my life with her it
was just it was
you know the life at the store wasn't
great yeah you know i was miserable
there yeah me too man that's what i
meant
she loved it though she loved being at
the store
that's crazy he was happy like she's
like loved working there and stuff
another man's trash is the other bird's
treasure dude that's really what it is
she enjoyed it huh
yeah and everything seemed set up for me
to be honest it was just
just present the ring ask her you know
and i yeah i i had a very bad breakdown
well i had to go to her and just tell
her like i can't keep doing this
you know how did she take that very bad
i was tough for her um i feel terrible
because she had to like skip work for a
couple days
you know but she was young you know and
in her mind like i said she's from the
appalachian like all her
friends are already married with three
kids um and she was 23-24
you know and she thought that her clock
was running out
i'm like do you have any idea how young
you are yeah
like you're like i don't know how it is
out there in the appellations
all my friends have three kids yeah 18
years old and they already start in
their life he was
born like do you understand i'm like
this last
one like that still doesn't have kids
all my friends are married with kids
like your friends are [ __ ] losers
yeah what else are they then
what are they doing you're the only one
that's not a [ __ ] loser right like
your life is more than just bearing
children you have
a lot more potential that's not her
dream her dream is to be a housewife
in a small little town in the middle of
nowhere the weird thing about that too
is like
i'm not judging that life path what i'm
saying is like it's not a very
hard thing to to achieve to do nothing
i mean okay let's not say that like not
have a job but
yeah she a guy just knows that's inside
you
yeah and then you have a kid like it's
not something you have to work that hard
for
she had no aspirations outside of being
a mother full time
which can be very beautiful like i said
but it's kind of weird like she's
talking about it as if her biological
clock is taking you 23 24. i'm used to
growing with
all my friends with bachelor's degrees
kind of yeah you know not all my friends
but like more than half you know and
i don't recall if she graduated high
school
really yeah i don't think we mentioned
it like but
i remember something where she had to be
taken out of school because of
like she had been bullied you know as a
child
because she loved a bunch of chinks
that's probably what it is but you like
them [ __ ] yellow skinned
[ __ ] but she was an outcast and
apparently
for these people out there like going to
the west coast
is like a big dream it's that's the
dream
you just go from one hillbilly town to
another hillbilly town on the west coast
but on the west coast
what the [ __ ] that's what she said like
these appalachian people like
because like west virginia all this [ __ ]
those mining towns
yeah like that's where she came out of
and ended up in like seattle yeah well
that's the weird thing because when i
was finding out about
kind of um how you know how we talk
about
ethnic diversity in this country right
and i think because we live in these
heavily populated
metropolitan areas for a majority of our
life we think that
the cultural diversity that we've
experienced growing up is reflected in
the other parts of this country and it's
not like when i found out that
asian people only make a 5.6 percent of
this country
i was like damn that's a little last
number bro it's very small i thought it
was a lot bigger than that
i thought it was at least like 10 15
percent it's 5.6
man now i understand like when you know
asian people on social media nobody sees
that [ __ ] yeah
because it's like 5.6 and then maybe
like point five percent is online
you know right posting stuff on social
media like that so now i can kind of see
i'm like oh i i
it might not be because we're not loud
enough it's just there's not enough of
us so we need like other allies to speak
for us right
you know and so when i saw that number i
was shocked it's like 5.6
man it's [ __ ] nothing i feel like
understand what it's like to be
one person yeah that's crazy because i
don't know what that's like i've
lived every place that i've lived in
i've seen people who look like me all
the time
i felt i felt extreme isolation
you know growing up through high school
and whatever and going back there for
work
it's just feels lonely even if you're
around as
many white people you can at walmart
yeah i just
feel so isolated and alone i don't know
what it is
i just want to meet this girl and just
bring her to like a big city
like go to just go to seattle no she's
scared
what's gonna happen a robot's gonna pick
her up and then put him in his backpack
like what the [ __ ] is she scared of like
she like even the idea of like like
living in l.a is just just like ah
like what does she think is gonna happen
i have no idea like she comes from a
very very
small town you know out she just took
her on the ferry and took her to seattle
like hey
you need to see the city no should we
did we did we would go and
and like i i'm more of the type that
would love to live
in the city yeah i'm not now if she
wants to live
very far away and have space for her
horse
and her bunnies and her dogs god damn
man
i mean i think that's very admirable for
somebody to find joy in the small things
like that yeah
i cannot like i need yeah me too i
i want to go to the big city i like
concrete jungle
um but i've also met other dudes um
that were the complete opposite of me
where they had a
great paying job in seattle and they
just wanted to run the kage with their
parents
you know just take care of them that's
all he wanted to do he's a super dope
created guy
and he like he just makes good money
anyway just running this
uh poke shop and and um this little
grocery store
you know and i was like maybe i should
you know learn to be like him and like
appreciate all this and i try that and
these
[ __ ] just don't stop [ __ ]
attacking me yeah [ __ ] that dude
i can't do that man like like i can be a
business owner and stuff too
which is perfectly fine which i am but
being at
maybe it's because i grew up being in a
business my whole life
i could see the repetition killing me on
the inside yeah you know
the repetitive stuff where every day
feels like the same and that's the part
that scares me
where every day feels the same it's like
clock in clock out clock in clock out
because i'd rather just work with
regular nine to five at that point
why why be a business owner also also
with the thought of
i when i open the door you know like
who's gonna start some [ __ ] with me
today yeah
when am i going to have my panic attack
and anxiety attack
you know and lose my [ __ ] you know yeah
that was the
kind of situation where i was in where i
was finally like
i can't do this every day people aren't
supposed to stress out
this bad every day people shouldn't be
on their toes
ready to be attacked every day dude
that's how people lose their mind did
you see that video clip of this guy i
think it was out in pennsylvania
where it was it was essentially two
people that were arguing right so it was
a couple
that lived across the street from this
other guy you saw that right yeah
and i guess from what i read was that
couple was shoveling their snow onto his
driveway yeah so clearly they've had
something that was going on between them
we don't know what it is obviously from
what happened at the end result we don't
know why that happened but that's not
something that happens just
in one day yeah they've done this
multiple times and maybe he's done it to
them it's like a back and forth thing
yeah
so you know it starts off they're
yelling at each other
and he's what was the agitator that he
was calling him he's like you're a
like nut job or something or a weasel or
something something really mild yeah you
know
and then he's like screw you or whatever
he's like no you
are whatever and they're going back and
forth back and forth the guy go back
he goes back in the house yeah he had a
[ __ ] handgun and then let me tell you
something
this is the craziest part about it the
girl looks at him and she goes what are
you gonna do
yeah i think i saw that i remember that
yeah she's like
she goes what are you gonna do you shoot
me i would never
in my life will say that to somebody
with a [ __ ] gun
what is that kind of security where
you have that kind of suburban american
security like that you're okay from a
gun i've never seen somebody point a gun
and she goes what are you gonna do shoot
me i'm like yes
[ __ ] that's the objective yeah and then
he comes out
has his handgun blasts her like point
blank and blastes the other dude right
here's now when you guys if you guys
ever see this clip online it's pretty
gruesome right yeah however there's one
part where i died laughing
so he's like executioner style blasting
her in the head right
even as she's getting shot that [ __ ] is
still talking [ __ ]
oh my god did you hear the audio no
she's like she gets
shot i'm talking executioner style right
she's looking at this dude still talking
[ __ ]
what as he put a bullet through her head
i'm like
yo i was like can i i had to run it back
for a second i'm like
how much of an [ __ ] is this woman
that
as she's being execution killed she's
still talking [ __ ] calling him a [ __ ]
all the way to the end yeah that's
pretty gangster i was like
i've never [ __ ] you yeah she says karen
till the end
she's like telling him to come close
come close you're a [ __ ]
i just want to let you know your mom's a
[ __ ]
and then he comes back out gets an
automatic rifle and finishes the job
on both of them over snow
over some snow [ __ ] or something else
and it was one of the neighbors heard
some [ __ ] and they came over to the lady
and she's all bleeding
and he goes hey are you okay
oh my god yo what do you mean bro she
just got shot the [ __ ]
are you okay where are these people and
it's what part of america
this is like pennsylvania or some [ __ ]
but
he apparently goes back into the house
and he kills himself
right yeah so and and the story to that
i yeah i didn't obviously did not do
that but
i did lose my [ __ ] a lot and it's not
helpful
towards the customers because when i get
snappy
but how can i when one guy comes in says
something shitty
and leaves and i still feel shitty i'm
an extra shitty for being shitty to the
next customer because of what the last
guy
yeah and i catch myself doing that man
you just never know what the [ __ ]
somebody else is going to do man you
just gotta leave that [ __ ] alone man
you gotta let people when somebody says
just words to you let it just be words
it's not
worth like losing your life over you
know yeah so it calls him i think he
calls him a scumbag i think that's the
adjective he said you're a scumbag or
something like that
i'm like that's it that's all it took
yeah
and that guy was like i think he was
like a military vet too i think he was
in the navy or some [ __ ] but you know he
obviously had weapons i'll tell you
like people kept telling me to get a gun
they're like why don't you have a gun
man like every time i post like
these videos some [ __ ] it's
constantly from my friends they're just
like get a gun get a gun i'm like
why wouldn't if i have never been in a
situation where i have been actually
held up
or anything but like or had a gun
pointed at me anywhere near my
store you know um and that that was the
reality of it for as long as i've been
there
and how shitty people can be i've only
had to deal with things with my hands
you know or my words yeah and
when i would at least use my words first
and have to just be
sharp with my words with them um
i could see that they were like i said
they're just having a bad [ __ ] day
and blaming on this guy
nobody knows yeah you know just go to
the gas station and give it on me
and i think and i just was not gonna be
that guy yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
this is a very scary situation too
because like guns have always freaked me
out
just because of how lethal it is yeah i
think what the the crazy thing about
that video was i was like
man these movies are [ __ ] fake as
[ __ ] you just get shot once and die
this [ __ ] was talking [ __ ] yeah she got
[ __ ] shot in the brain
dude she was still talking [ __ ] like you
buzzy [ __ ] i'm like
damn girl like what the [ __ ] this goes
down as [ __ ]
so maybe that's why what like have you
ever heard of people committing suicide
with two bullet holes in their head
oh yeah yeah yeah you think that's maybe
because oh
[ __ ] yeah i just didn't do the job i had
to do it twice yeah
which is [ __ ] like and you hear a lot
of stories of people getting shot in the
head and surviving too right
yeah he didn't do a good enough job dude
he obviously missed the part of the
brain where she
was the [ __ ] talking parts she was going
off on him i'm like damn dude this girl
is
nuts i wonder if she's the reason why
that [ __ ] started popping off because
she wouldn't
they were they were going out he said
you're a scumbag no scroll you you're a
scumbag
[ __ ] you so these people like also being
in quarantine in close vicinity right
and then you're in a winter storm and
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] all that dude like
i'm
i always tell people it's not worth it
man like is it ever worth losing your
life just to talk a little [ __ ]
like honestly like like the snow thing i
understand too like i'm not the best
like i've lost my temper too but
when somebody brings a gun out dude
that's when you get really
run or get i wouldn't ran if he came out
with a gun i was like hey bro
let me tell you something god loves you
you know this is jesus christ
due to christ let me get some brownie
points in before i go yeah
i i would be i would be like oh [ __ ]
maybe i [ __ ] with the wrong person
yeah but you just never know man some
people get really lucky they get brave
they get to talk their [ __ ] and they go
to the bar and they
tell their friends about oh this person
that they told off and they get really
hot about that [ __ ] one day you're gonna
run into the wrong [ __ ] person
okay so there's this old man
right that came to my store every day
this awesome guy with a beard
little loose teeth but he's a he's an
engine he's building his own plane in
his backyard oh wow
that kind of hillbilly what the [ __ ]
dirty all the time and he's building a
plane
he brought me his blueprints they're
legit he's building he's an engineer
you know um and
i would cook him sous-vide steak just
and then
he said it was the dope-ish so he took
my sears all and like did some
custom like attachments to it so it's
like fits better on my torch for me um
and one day this guy this meth head
[ __ ] he's constantly stealing from us
but my mom has known him for the last 20
years
from like out of high school right yeah
and he just grew up just to this be his
method he's still there
and he keeps stealing [ __ ] and my mom
keeps letting him do it
and then go until i was finally just
i had to tell him like dude just my mom
lets you
come here all the time and you
constantly steal and you steal and you
steal like
i don't understand her but i was just
like you should just not come
leave or whatever and then he try to
fight me
like and get in my face let it go
whatever right and then um
that man came by and i was visibly upset
you know he's like what's wrong you know
what's going on
you know and that guy you know he came
by again he stole this beer
and this gas or whatever and
let's just uh call him jim bob you know
jambop you're calling about jim bob
mcclure obviously not his
real damage making up you're talking
about jim bob
that the one that steals from he stole
my property
out of my garage if i see him i'll kill
him
um he's getting madder than me yeah and
i'm like you know
okay he's like no i'm serious i'm gonna
kill him
okay you know and i'm checking him out
he's like mark my words
and he goes to his car and then i hear
him he goes to the passenger side
he goes look and he pulls out an ak-47
holy [ __ ] i'll kill him and i was like i
believe you
i will he gets a [ __ ] uh a dummy doll
he has a knife
just like me it just saws the head off
dude he looks like he's like a real-life
tone mater
from cars come to life so lucky he's
your friend yeah yeah i'm so lucky he's
on my side
yeah so it's like so those people are
real too man
and why would i want a gun around that
[ __ ] too like
i don't want to put a gun in my hand
where i am not trained as
this crazy guy over here literally
i believe you no no like seriously
lay down on the floor so i can show you
what he'll look like
brains out here yeah he hey i've heard
man people [ __ ] shoot each other out
there man
oh i believe the [ __ ] method got shot
the meth had shot one of your [ __ ]
workers in his chest
my mind my mom will always be like hey i
haven't seen you a long time no see
where you been in jail
she says that all the time they're like
yeah yeah they were
like [ __ ] funny dude hey long time no
see you go to jail
how's jail how's it how's the jail they
have a good food
that's kind of nice i guess because this
kid
[ __ ] stabbed his stepfather in the
[ __ ] leg with a fork during
thanksgiving you know or not
dude you know it's not dude jail's no
[ __ ] joke man like a buddy of mine
too he jumped
he told me the story where um he
actually just came over the other day
yeah
and he was telling me the story about
how when he was young because he's a
very calm guy and i was asking him like
dude because he's going through some
[ __ ] right now and i'm like you have a
very
very calm demeanor like i wouldn't be
able to handle the situation that you've
been and he goes well i've
you know i'm calm now but you know when
i was younger because he he used to live
i think he was a
group of flushings like new york like i
did a lot of like [ __ ] and you know from
that i kind of learned
you know how to like control my temper
and you know just better manage these
situations and he was telling me the
story
about when he was in so he went to jail
not prison right so jail
and he was held up in there because he
got into a fight with his dude that he
[ __ ] hated
yeah over like some racing [ __ ] i don't
know what happened right yeah
but they got they get they don't put you
in separate jail cells right they do
have separate but they kind of put them
all in the same one
right and so like he heard back in the
day that when you're in jail you can't
look like a [ __ ] so if you say you're
gonna do some [ __ ] you have to do some
[ __ ]
so he's sitting down and he's looking
across at the at the other guy that he
got into a fight with which is the
reason why that they're
locked up and the guy looks over at him
and kind of like jedi boss
like kind of gives him a dirty look and
he says to him he goes
the [ __ ] are you looking at and he knew
because somebody told them
ahead of time that if you say something
like that you have to finish what you
start yeah
they start scrapping and fighting or
whatever and what happens is they get
he gets pushed all the way into another
cell and now he's already pissed and
upset
so a few days go by or whatever and he's
like yelling at the cops now my buddy
he's like yo when the [ __ ] am i gonna
see a [ __ ] judge get me out of this
[ __ ] jail cell yeah
and these cops are looking i'm like nope
just walking away
so when you're in jail after like six
days you get sent
to prison he will get he will after six
days you don't see a judge
until you see a judge they don't hold
you there for however long
after six days you get sent to rikers
and so
he's sitting here and he's getting super
[ __ ] upset
and then finally on the sixth day he's
like yo i gotta see a judge today if not
i have to go to rikers island yeah
and so he gets there and he goes hey
officer
i would just like to apologize for the
way that i was speaking to you
you know i was just upset but may i
please ask you
when can i see a judge and he looks at
him he goes hold on
comes back he goes you'll see a judge in
an hour and he goes the way that you
speak to us and how you behave
is really going to depend on how how
good your life is so yeah you apologize
oh i can't do prisoner jail dude like
it's it's [ __ ] nuts
yeah and those ceos too like they don't
have an option
of showing you mercy because the moment
that you show they show you mercy
you're you you'll get [ __ ] taken over
and your convict number
one million that went through exactly
why would they give a [ __ ] like
like my buddy chris he was a ceo and he
told a story too where
you know he showed up one day and he had
braids in his hair and they just kept on
calling him alicia keys like
all the prisoners alicia keys
and they were just you know cracking
jokes at him he's like oh [ __ ] because
you know you show any sign of weakness
they'll they'll take advantage of you
yeah and so they weren't gonna give him
[ __ ] until he apologized and when he
apologies softened up they're like okay
cool you'll see a judge today
and then he didn't get he didn't go to
rikers dude i'm saying i can't handle
going to jail man i already know for a
fact
i spent a night in jail and i'll tell
you it
[ __ ] sucks was it for trunk tank yeah
oh god yeah and well here's the thing
they put me in a warm cell at first and
i was like all right
then i was gonna go to sleep they wake
i i actually didn't even get a chance to
fall asleep i was just sitting in there
and then they pulled me on put
this put me in this freezing cold cell
with other like heroin addicts
where they have to like detox and get
clean yeah they put me in there with
them
and then there was a running tv of the
city like jail system in english for 30
seconds then spanish 30 seconds and it
repeated
for eight hours oh my god i would lose
my [ __ ] mind
yeah dude and i was in there and this
thing was blasting
for eight hours straight in loop
yeah and i was like sitting there like
why am i here like
i didn't like i was like i i i thought i
was just putting that gel and i
i didn't think i did anything wrong but
yeah they threw me in there it was just
like there was like other drunk people
in there too and it was warm
yeah i ended up in this cool tank and
what the [ __ ]
until [ __ ] i got out like they gave
me a sack lunch
and i was i was hungry but
something about it smelled funny and
just disgusting yeah yeah
so i gave it to the other guy i just
drank the milk
and when i was getting out and
getting my clothes back and all my [ __ ]
the officer was handing me my wallet
he goes do you want your mug shot
and i'm like no because are you sure
it'll remind you every time you're a
[ __ ] idiot
i'm almost ready to cry already yeah
just put my clothes on and i got out oh
my gosh and then just
to see the signing out of there was such
a relief but my [ __ ] phone was dead
i'm gonna go find some pay phone or call
somebody pick me up
that's [ __ ] crazy that guy just had
to dig one in right at the end
oh man yeah i i it was unnecessary yeah
i learned the lesson though man i will
never [ __ ] go back dude
like but you heard um was it a mod arbor
you have you heard that story
um uh the
guy who got shot running no it was the
kid who had um
he had a he went to jail because
somebody said he stole a backpack
uh i i know that this yeah yeah this
[ __ ] went to rikers
yeah he went to [ __ ] rikers for i
think it was three years
for something that he didn't even
[ __ ] do which blew my [ __ ] mind
because i can only imagine what it's
like
to go to jail for something you
did not do and rikers island
like one of the craziest penitentiaries
out there for something you didn't
[ __ ] do
and i went in with something i did and i
had time to think
yeah about my the consequences of my
actions yeah i'm not gonna go
if i didn't do anything yeah i'd
just go crazy you would lose you would
lose your [ __ ] mind and it was crazy
because jay-z
um he obviously put a lot of press on it
and you know dropping all the charges
and everything else like that
and his life was going to get together
but he had all these demons inside that
he couldn't get rid of and he killed
himself yeah
which [ __ ] blows my mind dude his
like his whole
past and his history is really sad right
so his
dad wasn't around his mom was i believe
his mom was like a method or a crackhead
or some [ __ ] like that
so you know he obviously didn't grow up
in the best issues so he was a crack
baby
and then when his father found out that
he was in jail
yeah he didn't care he was like oh he's
in rikers he goes he probably deserved
it
and kind of just you know left him to
stew in there
it was it was pretty bad and you hear
about this kid's story all because
somebody
accused him of something that he didn't
[ __ ] do i cannot go to jail
i spent one night i spent one night and
my dad was in
for 14 months that's crazy and he came
back
like i said just different different
yeah
um i don't know it it
it's not somewhere you want to go and
trust me it's not like a
i don't know a plaque thing on your
thing i i don't like telling people i
even went to jail
yeah you know but um yeah it's it's a
lesson learned um obviously because you
have a lot of time to think
but 14 [ __ ] months that one night i
spent there
and my dad had already passed by this
time i was just thinking
[ __ ] you know just about his situation
and not ever understanding until i spent
one day
you know you kind of lose your humanity
a little bit it's not like they treat
you like a human being they treat you
like chattel
yeah right and then you have to figure
out this game like i had a business
partner he went to jail for a year
and like he was telling me what it was
like in there and it [ __ ] sucks dude
like yeah
you lose your humanity like when you
lose your humanity you you i would lose
my sanity
i the idea of freedom is really
comforting like the idea that you can
choose to leave whenever you want yeah
that is something that we all take
granted for
like when once that's taken away you
start to realize like how
how [ __ ] your whole world just starts
to spiral
yeah it's like i don't have a choice if
i could leave or even the decisions that
are suddenly made for you
yeah you don't know what you eat yeah
when you sleep
when you wake up like [ __ ] man is this
how it's going to be i ca i ca
i can't imagine what that shit's like
yeah yeah
and so when my dad got out he just
wanted to be
free and he did a lot of [ __ ] just
on his own freedom because he hadn't
experienced it in such such a long time
yeah
but he went overboard i'll tell you
crazy yeah for sure
i mean my one of my um church tongues
back in the day he was he went to jail
because he was uh jacking cars
yeah and then um when he came out he
told me that in in the first
week or was it the first night i can't
remember it's been a while now but he
heard some dude
getting um raped like getting butt raped
just [ __ ] muffled and screaming i'm
like
hell [ __ ] no how did you survive like
same thing all asian dudes you gotta
gang up
and he was like a big buff dude so i
just ganged up and i you know i stayed
deep in that
click and then i just then i got out
after and he was in jail for like three
years
or some [ __ ] for like robbing a bunch of
cars can't do it man
yeah my i think one of these producers i
worked with
this dude was just yoked and jacked up
just because he was
when he was getting sentence he knew he
was going to be there for like 90 days
or something
yeah and so he got jacked just and then
from what he said he was just like all
he had to do was just be like hey i'm
just doing my
time i'm working out don't mess with me
yeah and as far as
like the washington state prisons i
guess that's as much as a he got paid
oh really yeah well our friend who went
to doe she she got really fat because
she says like
yeah you if you got fat they don't mess
with you
yeah so she got she gained an
exponential amount of weight
and then when she went to jail that's
why she got so big if you're skinny they
pick on you
i guess they pick on you or you look
cute or whatever you're trying to look
as ugly as possible or
like unattractive you know in the
traditional sense so she got really
slovenly and that's what suggested to
her before she went in yeah it was funny
because she went to a satellite prison
which is basically a college campus
yeah i'm like the [ __ ] you made it sound
like you went to like you did a hard
time [ __ ] like you went to a [ __ ]
satellite prison dude yeah the satellite
prison is almost
like rehab uh well i'm glad that
we want we want people to go to rehab
though right to be rehabilitated
i would hope our friends don't get
punished honestly but the way she talked
about it
i was like oh it's like it's a [ __ ]
hard [ __ ] i remember she didn't want to
tell me where she was going
where are you going and i looked it up i
was like wait you're going to a
satellite prison [ __ ]
it's not even [ __ ] prison the [ __ ]
you talking about she wanted to make it
sound like it was super hard or some
[ __ ] i'm like you're weird dude
i would if i was i would tell people
like i'm going to satellite i got lucky
yeah you know what i'm saying i learned
a lesson
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain
uh you can find ed at ed parkvp and
jesus brings every thursdays
and sundays hope you guys enjoyed that
conversation you guys can listen to us
anytime you want and we'll catch you all
next time peace peace